UN Ambassador nikki Haley suggests that
the Trump administration will take
action if the international community
fails to respond to the chemical attack
in Syria holding up photos of victims
Haley blamed Russia for protecting the
Assad government children foaming at the
mouth
suffering convulsions being carried in
the arms of desperate parents look at
those pictures
we cannot close our eyes to those
pictures Holly Williams is along the
turkey-syria border with the latest on
the inland province attack and the
victims there a warning these images are
quite disturbing Holly good morning good
morning autopsies on some of those
killed in this attack proved that a
chemical weapon was used
that's according to Turkey's justice
minister speaking earlier today Abdul
Hameed audiosurf lost his nine month-old
twins in the attack on the town of
Honshu who their names are iron and
honored he said say goodbye my love he
buried them yesterday along with their
mother even in the hell of Syria's Civil
War this attack was notable for its
barbarism men women and children left
gasping for air and foaming at the mouth
autopsies on three of those who lost
their lives were carried out at this
Turkish forensics Institute according to
local media reports they died after
being ferried into the country for
treatment with around 30 others
survivors who've been brought here to
Turkey can be tested for exposure to a
chemical agent but across that border
inside the war zone gathering evidence
is more difficult and more dangerous in
Honshu hoon the streets are now
unnaturally quiet two days after this
atrocity many of its residents have fled
but some are taking samples from the
scene of the attack they want to prove
what it was that killed their loved ones
mohammad abu joseph says he watched his
mother father and nephew die screaming
it's a chemical attack and says but you
don't think about running away you try
to help people and carry them out of
there
Syria's foreign minister spoke just a
short while ago and claimed that the
Syrian regime has not and will not use
chemical weapons against its own people
Charlie thanks Holly Holly Williams in
Turkey everybody is
if I'd buy those pictures right